einstein's theory of relativity is the
most important theory in the in the
whole universe
but einstein theory is still incomplete
we need to go beyond
einstein that is why i try to do in
microservice use precision cosmology and
try to deal now with a new theory that
can defy even eyes theory
the moment when i decided to become a
cosmologist was very important for me
i was very little four years old
one pop of a question came to me
and the question that remains on today
was what is the age of the universe
at that moment i started to think what
kind of science i can study in order to
answer this question
ancestor relativity have
many many problems it's a beautiful
theory mathematical theory the problem
is that are forces that are living in
different levels of energy gravity is
very small electromagnet is very strong
so when he tried to make this
unification he didn't get it
it was impossible mathematically
[Music]
he needed to add something by hand
this something is the cosmological
constant and he added by hand in order
to have this universe evolving and
evolving evolving and have this
expansion of itself but what was the
problem the problem is that this
cosmological constant cannot be related
with a quantum world with a small world
so the cosmologists assume that there is
something extreme in universe so this is
what we call dark energy
that energy is the simple explanation of
the expansion of the universe and if we
link this with the age of the universe
we will have
a massive answer to what is happening at
the very beginning
precision cosmology now is the hot
science i must say why because now we
are leaving the data analysis era
if you want to do precision cosmology
you need the machine learning techniques
you need computers so machine learning
can process data of different kinds at
different velocity and from every corner
of the universe
with precision cosmology we try to
explain alternative theory of gravity
we are looking for a theory that
naturally can give you this is that
energy this is that matter without
imposing anything by hand
then they try to explain a very simple
object that now we got a photograph of
this organ the famous black hole
with this second photograph of the even
horizon telescope now we have the very
proof that our magnetic fields surround
these big monsters so the next step is
to try to understand which kind of
theory of gravity that can make this
unification between gravity and
electromagnetism and also can describe
these black holes so that was the first
thing that i wanted to know if there is
another kind of theory that can do the
same as einstein
[Music]
so einstein's theory of regulatory we
have curature a big mass in universe can
make this curator in the space time
we need another word a very a kind of
funny word a torsion so it's like having
tornadoes in in every part of the
universe so intel parallel with these
little tornadoes with these little
torsions living in different places of
the universe we can explain for example
that energy einstein's theory of
regulatory cannot do this
teleparallel gravity is like a theory
that complements a general relativity
when you go closer to the to the big
band the general relativity imposed by
einstein cannot explain this kind of a
scenario so telepara gravity can't
explain this
so maybe this tornadoes these twist
things in the universe can explain the
fierce galaxies at the very beginning
one of the experiments that we hope to
have at hand very soon is the james webb
telescope if the james webb telescope
now that is in the space recovers data
from the very very early universe maybe
we can have now at hand the very proof
that telepara gravity is even
a theory that completes einstein's
stream
[Music]